all right can anyone play the guy with walls wait what we
can't we can't we can't i play shard girl okay none of us
you know i think he's a scissor character we are so i wanted
to play the i wanted to play the reichie guy his guns based
okay that's the wall guy hey guys hey everybody i'm live
right now by the way i'm live right now i go i go be listen
to me this is the strat first round you buy one one uh thing
and then if next round if you don't have enough money for
armor sell whatever you bought and buy armor because okay
because i armor it's like on the right side it's just armor
press b press b sure for yeah press b i bought damage why do
i go a or b i bought damage too i'm b i put turrets on b um
it's not a it's not b Nobody needs to do mid.
Nobody's looking at mid.
We don't need mid.
What if they fucking rush mid?
We're getting walled.
They put a wall on A.
They're going A.
These guys have strats.
Okay.
Yeah, that's what I'm already.
What?
Dude, I gotta fucking run down.
Oh.
Okay.
He's looking at me with an auto sniper.
This is a mess already.
Their own point?
I got one.
Oh, guys, no.
Okay.
They planted the bomb.
I got one.
I got one on the ground.
yeah oh oh my right behind me right here right here it's a
2v2 situation it's a 2v2 situation i am okay right now one
v2 one v2 last guy one v2 last guy i'm not raising i'm not
raising okay yeah you fucking crawl on the floor there all
right for those who don't know for in my chat we just
started tournament it was there was no breaks we just went
straight let's go next whoa oh my god who's that guy with
three kills i don't know man who is that wow is that the top
20 overwatch player wait how do you know about that what the
fuck because i was like who the fuck is this guy that's on
our team i feel like he's top 20.
i can actually support him i can shield the i'm i don't know
what's my character don't i don't even know what your
character what are you playing press f1 press f1 and leave
press f1 and leave Read between rounds.
This is going great, Chris.
We're doing great, guys.
We're doing great.
I need to fix my game after.
There's no breaks in any.
Oh, yeah, they're good.
They're here.
They're testing us.
They're going B now because A didn't work.
Yeah, they know the best player is at A.
Yeah, I was on A.
I'm not peeking.
No, I'm talking about the actual best player.
Okay.
Hi.
Oh, my God.
I'm dying.
I'm trying.
I put them on the ground.
Thank you.
We didn't thirst in though.
Well, I was reloading.
I'm looking at the side here.
I'm not in a good position.
Yeah, they did.
Oh, no, there's one more.
One more.
No, they're just staying.
They're staying.
See?
Okay.
I'm just gonna put turrets back then.
I wanna play solo.
They might be rotating.
I don't know.
They're playing super slow.
I have a big circle thing.
They have a big circle.
Here, here, here.
beat or back in D.
Wait, what?
Oh, they baited.
Play retake?
You want to play retake?
We got this, right?
Yeah, we can play retake.
We knocked one.
We got one down.
Yeah, we're coming back.
We're coming over.
One top left.
One top left ramp to our left.
Let's pull a rush ramp.
I'm heading over.
I might die doing this.
Oh, there's three guys here.
There's three guys here.
I'm here.
We're here.
We're here .лохo.
blind me when i go through it man i got one uh one slow
ming's low ming's low next behind me yeah yeah nice one more
one more one more one more no no it's all dead all wait yeah
we naturally know oh we got me i mean are we no no i carry
guys bro you have no ping you you have to use your peekers
advantage bro yeah that's on me okay i still don't have i
went in first why am i getting I was talking about next.
Oh, okay.
Okay, so now buy the thing.
Am I supposed to buy armor?
I'm buying.
I refunded some shit.
I refunded something for it.
Don't have a heavy shield.
Buy the light regen shield.
Wait, don't buy heavy shield.
Why not?
But it's heavy.
Because it doesn't regen.
Oh.
Regen is so much better.
Yeah, but I'm going to die anyway.
I'm not going to live long enough.
I'm not going to live long enough to regen.
Guys, I'm going to hold next.
Can you back?
You see the back out.
I can like cue you.
Like just give a sign first.
I can also fly.
They're mid.
I got a combo in mid.
Yeah, I see them.
They're KO-knifing me.
KO-knifing on me.
I've been spotted.
I'm smoking.
Ow.
They got mid.
They're close.
Mid to A.
Mid to A again.
Oh, that's you're okay.
I'm going back.
I'm coming to you guys.
Next night.
I'm going to anchor just in case they come back.
I downed one.
Oh, yeah.
Nice, nice.
Good job.
Keep downing people.
I'm going to flank.
Okay, throw an aid.
Guy invisible on point, I kind of fucked him up.
You guys want to push?
I can flash it.
Flashing?
Oh boy, I got one, I got one, I got one.
One on point, one on point.
In the corner, invisible.
Oh, I'm down.
Oh, I used here!
I was trying Thursday.
We went in one by one.
We need more on A, I think.
More on A.
We have more on A.
two we had two on b i was on mid oh okay i'm rolling back
and forth but the thing is like if you get a knock we just
you guys have nades yeah i do have a nade i just need them
when they're playing behind a thing like here control them
just need it that's true i have nades i flash i flash all
them i've been called okay i have my turret i have my all i
can use my ult for take back.
What does your ult do?
My ult, I throw a fucking turret.
Oh yeah, it's ult here.
Yeah, yeah.
I can use my ult for take back here.
It's not me.
Oh, it's me.
Oh, it's mid.
Yeah, I see them.
I'm gonna throw my turret right now!
I'm gonna do it!
Doki run?
Doki, that's a whole team on you?
I know, I know.
That's why I threw my turret, because I was scared.
They're fucking killing my turret.
He's dead.
instantly they're pushing donkeys someone's pushing donkeys
they're all low at do it you're all so low go go go push
push oh no blind through my my grenade there how long is you
i don't want that one i got one i got one behind me more
nice one on the right side yeah yeah go crazy i can't see
anything i'm going crazy by crazy i mean i'm not hitting
anything i think i think your 200 ping is actually doing
stuff right now oh my god ping dude okay if you get a full
send just tell me and i'll hold you it's like yeah i did say
i did say yeah but i didn't okay so okay guys calm down
everyone calm down by the way just so you guys know defense
is harder than attack You could just 5v1.
Yeah, attack you could just storm.
Wait, on this map?
I don't know.
I don't know if it's hard.
Guys, I have my...
I'm awake.
I'm a professional.
I'm professional.
I'm awakened right now.
Okay, I'm gonna...
I'm predicting a B push.
Yeah, but you don't even...
Sherry, do you know what your alt does?
It's...
He doesn't need to know.
He shoots her.
I'm KJL.
Okay.
It's KJL.
It's not B.
It's not me.
It's an A push.
I'm rotating.
I have my grenade pre-caught.
They're mid, mid, mid, mid, mid, mid.
Oh, they're mid, okay.
Oh, next, don't die, next!
No, I'm fine, I'm fine.
Well, I went out A though.
Yeah, they're also nading me from me.
They crossed from mid, they crossed from mid to A.
Yeah, me too, me too.
Okay, I'm going back to you then.
I'm fucking, they're wall hacking me, cheating, cheating.
Yeah, sure.
Oh my god, it's as if this...
They're smoking the point.
I'm just rolling the plan.
I got one, yeah, yeah.
I'm ulting A.
Oh, he's coming!
One more, one more, one, one more.
We got two.
Look at the wall hack.
Yeah, we're going.
We're going.
I'm flashing up.
We got another.
I knocked him.
I fixed him.
Last guy.
I'm waiting.
There you go.
I used KJ on.
I used me KJ on.
Nice KJ on.
Bro, fucking, I pin said I'm flashing him and I just so
fucking boom.
I have another I have another turret for a take back again I
it says I can teleport between my things how do I do that I
don't know I never play that guy i'm not no one's playing
chamber none of us play no i'm chamber and killjoy i got a
guy i said this is my awakening lets me teleport they're
going man wall hacking me i'm slowed throwing grenade out
i'm gonna throw my turret out i'm gonna do it made out wait
actually no never mind i'm not gonna do it i realized they
rotated they're on a their name they're on a terrible smoke
on a just I'm looking at one entered a once on a right now
inside wait for I'm throwing my turret I'm gonna do it.
I'm gonna do something fucking crazy.
Go cat go I mean all three push up.
What the fuck?
They're one No, there's a there's a sniper right here.
Half HP half HP I didn't see you Oh, I fucked up.
Oh my god.
I even used my turret cat Oh my god, next you got this this
i have a semi-auto weapon so i can't hold ramp if they three
man me
okay i'll i'll i'll play closer to you surfer oh i need to
turn sure down apparently burn me down yeah you're too loud
okay what if i turn you flank because i'm not like i'm full
support like i need i i always flank i just check if it's b
or and if it's not a flank on a sell this and then go for
what is this yeah i think if you thirst skill key thank you
this what do you when you thirst you like get all charge
like there's somebody's killer because i got my turrets so
fast probably so i guess it's just good to thirst in general
do you still want me to smoke this nice i thirst as soon as
i can yeah thirst too but like i got my turrets so fast
there
doing a all the time mid mid i saw someone in mid too mid
slowed me again yeah they're going to mid it's always a yeah
it's just always a i think they just know it works i'm just
gonna play close to you sure for this is where i got spotted
so they know i'm here wait someone's close oh yeah one right
here on point on point on a point oh i see i see Right here,
right here, right here.
The sniper's low.
One down, one down.
Someone on a gun.
There's it.
I'm blind!
What that was happening?
I'm dying too.
They're pushing the ramp, they're pushing the ramp.
Okay, okay, okay.
Yeah, they fucking killed me from ramp.
I'm pushing top right.
I'm maybe resable up here.
Maybe resable.
One high.
Just kill them all.
One more on high.
One more on ramp.
He's right above you, right above you.
I'm pushing with you.
I'm not there.
I can't climb this wall.
I thought I could paper the wall.
Dude, my SMG looking ass cannot handle this shit on the
fucking ramp, bro.
All right, here we go.
What does damage rad ratio mean?
Yeah, I don't know.
I just put that because it looked cool.
I bought it because it looked cool.
It's a string shield damage rad plus 25%.
I have no idea.
That's damage.
Oh, damage.
Okay, yeah, I bought that shit.
That's good shit.
I say red.
Nice.
Next, next, next.
Why is the damage red?
If they all come here, let's make a play, okay?
You back out and then I'll flash it and I'll ult you and you
just go in.
This is such a close game.
It's not B.
They're going.
Oh, yeah.
Never mind.
It is.
There's a lot B here.
Okay.
I see mid.
I'm flashing.
There's a lot.
They smoked mid and I'm a little paper boy.
We're stacking this shit.
They're here, they're here.
Behind you guys, behind you guys.
No no he is!
I have HP, HP, HP HP HP.
Who is?
Wait, they're all here.
They're all there, they're all low, they're all low!
My turrets, my tank guy!
Fuck you!
Where we died?
Where we died, where we died?
I'm raising doki, raising doki.
Oh, this is gonna be awkward.
They figured out my spread, guys.
I ulted.
I'm healing myself.
I'm doing shit.
It's actually winnable.
I need heal.
I'm doing shit today.
I kill it.
know i'm coming over i'm coming over i saw a name as a bat
where are they i think they're raising right here okay wait
they got me revealed what oh my god he's the one shot oh no
they're pushing the pushing no there's no way guys i think
the way to play this game is like oh we switched never mind
all right i don't know how to play this girl in attack I
think I'll play the flying woman how did they come behind us
next I don't know how that happens yes that's so fast I was
crazy they probably used the paper oh that's true they used
the paper for him pick a smoke grenade pick a smoke grenade
I'm gonna get a D go to what's the smoke grenade I didn't
get it I didn't get it I have frag grenades and heal grenade
What's the point of why plant the bomb when you can just
kill them?
Yeah, but how do you know we're gonna kill them?
How do you?
That's the thing.
That's the thing if you plant the bomb, we're sitting ducks,
you know, we just kill them.
We just leave the bomb and spawn.
Let's just leave it.
Okay, who wants the bomb?
I shouldn't be the bomb, Carrie.
Let's try and be.
I don't think I should either.
I can.
I'll be.
I'll play full support.
Like, let's go be a surfer.
Let's do a wall anywhere.
slow thing my wall stage anywhere you have abilities really
diagonal
we got spotted by the way like they scanned us so all of
them one's close one's close yeah yeah right here push push
push oh i hit that i slowed them i slowed them i slowed them
is that our wall there's it's ours yeah they're in that
corner thing oh okay i got hit by it do you want to...
Oh, we killed one.
Sheriff just killed someone?
Okay.
What the fuck?
I vented.
They're in the window there.
I'm beaming them in the window.
Oh shit.
Frag!
Whoa!
Oh shit, I got frag.
They're on the ramp here.
My ping.
Okay.
One down.
I'm above.
Above us.
Why is there a bomb?
I'm dead to an age.
Two here.
Oh, shit.
No, that guy was one.
I got one guy that was one.
I did kill.
Oh, he's pushing, he's pushing, he's pushing, he's pushing.
Nice.
Gotta get him off, I did.
Yeah, you did.
He's on me up top.
Okay, I'm dead.
Oh, it's that 1v1.
Wait, we got the bomb though.
You can stall it.
I'm dead.
No, you're not.
You got this, I believe.
Better aim.
Okay.
My gun is not built for close quarters.
I don't Did not expect my two players to just sit there and
get shot in the face when I said they're up top You said
he's up top and I died in the same second you said that he
was up top like I have no Okay, to be fair you guys should
not have been resing when there was just one person He just
no, no, it was two.
It was two.
Okay now you wait now you need to sell and buy armor
actually I have to sell okay Yeah, yeah, you're right now
the region did but we do it faster don't get stuck behind
let's get it all let's let's run all the way up here like
let's get control of this upper part they're gonna scout us
out they're gonna hit us yeah no no can we wait play live
forever back wait for them to use a scan don't just stun
okay i'm just gonna be paper i'm gonna be paper mario just
be paper i'm on the wall me too
uh it takes like six i've been spotted okay yeah maybe you
should have been there during paper mark i don't know how
long that's their okay let's go let's go that you can move
with the blood house scan i'm going a no no we're going b
we're going b no he's he's faking he's faking let him fake
oh yeah me and x are also faking i fucked up guys okay sure
for me don't well i was trying to build my wall and got i
got slowed i slowed him i slowed him okay i'm here guys this
is going great for us i'm not bombs okay i i hit somebody
with my name oh no one's covering you yeah no one is i'm
trying but i thought he said time was easier behind you guys
behind us no what the What the fuck happened?
What the fuck happened?
How many rounds is this too?
Let's try eight this time.
We still, we have, we have time to re-establish guys.
We have time.
We can stabilize.
Let's go, let's go, A, let's do something together once.
You mean together?
If we do something together, then we can win.
Come on.
Okay.
That sounds good.
That was my old dude.
Oh my god.
It makes your wall like the metro wall.
It's the Metro wall.
I only played this shit in the deathmatch mode, bro.
The gun is awesome.
So listen, if you use your wall and then you use your alt, I
think you get wall hacked through your wall.
And it blocks bullets, it said.
Nice.
Yeah, your alt blocks bullet.
Only your alt does.
You ping with Z, by the way.
Yeah.
Ah, they got fucking lasers.
They got lasers.
Oh, they're slowing us.
Chill, chill.
We're gonna go flying.
Okay.
We're not really looking at our flanks right now.
Not gonna lie.
I can use my alt, guys.
I'm gonna look at our flank.
They bubbled my alt.
Let's turn around.
Let's just fucking just go through a mid to B.
No, no, no.
Sit right here and then go A again, because I have my wall.
Okay, okay.
You've been spotted.
It's fine.
There's a queen on there.
The bear.
Bear scouting.
The bear knows where we're at now.
The bear still scouting.
Nobody shot the bear!
I shot the bear!
It's not easy!
Come down!
He's so big!
What do you mean he's not?
Okay.
I'm gonna put this in here.
That's my slow.
Okay, everyone should we have 55 seconds.
I can build another wall.
Wait, wait, wait, the ice is insane.
I'm building another wall.
A, I'm gonna cut all the people off in mid.
Alright.
We're going A, they know they know that we've been spotted
over.
We've been spotted for 20 hours.
Go go go kill the guy drab kill the guy on the ramp.
Oh my god.
You're fucking body blocking me I didn't think you would
walk backwards guys.
There's a guy back Where's the ramp?
We're a fucking mess guys I killed one not one wrap.
Oh my god.
I had to reload I said push a and no one pushed no one
pushed and then I body blocked you That's not with that's
two with me.
Wait, can I can I call?
Yes, please Okay, let me call Yeah, I don't trust our PRs
captain anymore.
We're gonna go a but don't stay with me like go further back
Don't get spotted The moment we execute just go in as fast
as you can it doesn't matter because like if the longer we
take they're gonna like I feel like we should just run in
instant instead of waiting I mean if you want to do that
Okay, all right.
Yeah, fuck you.
I'm not gonna call them.
Oh, let's go.
I mean I do If you're gonna call the call I'm not calling.
All I'm saying is all every single time we've waited they've
all just scanned and then ran out okay now they know because
they used the beer just push there's fucking yeah yeah i'm
pushing i'm pushing oh my god they grenade it they grenade
it okay all right you guys that's why you wait you guys
didn't want to push just push oh there's so much stuff going
on i can't see anything i can't see anything going on i'm
fucking needing smoking that off i can't see anything we run
it through mid we run it through mid yeah run that guy
running down running down there's one guy here he's one he's
one he's one i can't see there's three of them behind you
behind you behind you behind you behind you behind you
behind you there's two there's two behind there's two here
there's two here oh they they he was guys i think they're
more coordinated i think also when we push we don't corridor
no listen to me they have setups the scouts are out they
have scanner i think that's why you wait they're always
gonna scan us the guy on b has a long cooldown that's why
i'm i'm dude i'm not calling bro let's listen typing i feel
like he knows what he's doing all right i'm waiting i
thought you said defense was harder i thought you said
defense was I feel like attack was hiding.
This was gonna happen.
I feel like attack was hiding.
Okay, what are we doing, Igel?
I feel like this is not even the hardest.
Stand here, stand where Dogan, like where our car is.
Stay here for like at least just like four seconds.
We'll stay here, this is very close so we can actually
execute fast.
We're so far back.
Okay, okay, don't worry, I'm coming over then.
Oh shit, they pushed us.
We're so far back!
Did the waiting strat work?
they're cheating at this point all right we can we can
re-ask it on a like we play as a ball like they can't do
anything when we push like as a five man but do i am i
carrying the ball we're coming over oh yeah we could have
used this in time oh that's the bear kill the bear kill the
bear okay i almost killed someone i mean we can execute
faster like i have ulti nope i'm looking at our backs i'm
checking flanks to be what about yeah let's yeah let's do
that i'm all hacking i'm all i'm i'm here push push push
push i can ult you if you when you okay this is free this is
free bomb down planting the bomb yeah i hit a lot of people
there oh i got it knocked but we knocked one i'm queuing you
after oh there's two here this drop there's one around the
corner yeah is that one on me three three i killed the robot
There's two on top.
Three V2.
Oh, it's fine.
I'm going to awaken.
Oh, no, you are not awakening.
Jokes over your day.
Hey, guys, I think this team is better.
I feel like if we did this earlier, instead of fucking
yapping 24-7, we would actually have a chance in attack.
Oh, hey, I'm second top fraggy.
Second!
I feel like we need a new document.
We continue.
Hey guys, I feel like ping.
Oh wait, no, next.
Never mind.
Next is you.
Yeah.
Guys, I had 11 knocks.
Yeah, but you didn't finish them.
I'm a DMR player.
How can I just look at the chat?
So wait, is this like we play one map only?
only one match per team yeah and then we play a different
team yeah we fucking suck we need to consider our live
choices right guys right yeah i thought you said you're
gonna make a team that's gonna win this like what was what
was you can't win if people don't listen well we did and
then the guy just ran it down and then the guy just ran it
down mid and shot us listen you're uncoachable like I can't
help you I literally got a second fragger you can't say that
what did that do for us what did that do for us that would I
do we got like four to nine or five now I don't know you
know I think we need to put surefer on sniper rifle he was
on sniper this entire time I'm on DMR if you hit headshot
boom dead yeah but if you miss then you're useless for five
minutes that's so true
unbelievable this guy's a level 30 bro not fair bro you
could have grinded this game whenever hope the highest level
in here what are you talking about i'm level five he's level
five why aren't you level 30 why didn't you grind this game
rpr I'm not captain.
I'm not captain.
And I have a life outside of...
No, you don't.
Yes, I do.
I can stream other things.
Okay, how do we...
How do we literally destroy it?
I don't...
What do you mean?
We don't have a room code yet.
Yeah, we're not going to go on for a while.
We've got to go practice now.
Oh, no.
And make a custom room.
Leave and make a custom.
minute break so there's a 30 minute break we lost too fast
don't we do need that 30 minutes yeah let's go starts at 3 p
.m pst all right okay guys we need to get in the custom wait
wait how many games do we have so three games you guys are
scheduled for one two three games uh you will end off at 330
pst oh okay i was gonna be like shit i have to leave at 3 30
so we're gonna try to see if we can end you off a little
earlier okay i will end the shutter off a little earlier as
it seems okay so what's the strat rpr can i can i ask
something how many in here has played either cs or valerant
in a at a high level at a high level uh i got to radiant huh
i'm a cs surf professional okay so it's like radiant concept
of baiting out fucking utility, right?
They're going to use scan.
The bear is like a fucking Sova drone.
Just kill it.
And then they're going to re-rotate all the time.
It's about playing the re-rotation all the time.
You bait utility, you try and make them to rotate, and you
execute fast.
By holding it together, it's like if one of them peaks and
you know, if he caught, you can literally run him down.
Or you can choose to just re-rotate another place.
It's about map.
What's it called map coverage.
You play the information game, and then once you get it, you
can execute.
but like they don't have our and sucks yeah but but they
don't have unlimited utility that's why you bait it out we
have like two minutes like three minutes or something that's
why you play hard you use the scan and they have to get and
if we go let's say as an example when we went a you started
using all the utils on us right that's why we pressure mid
or b and then we could just execute a afterwards because
they used everything agree but that doesn't matter but that
But that doesn't matter If five people just cause five
different things Who's gonna I gel?
You I gel I'm not the people don't listen to me You I gel
it's over Okay when you say people don't listen to you It's
literally just sure for it Actually actually if you look at
the recording When he said okay go A I was the only one on
top of it When you three were jerking off in a corner I was
getting shocked Even on ramp, I don't know if you remember,
Shuffle, when three people just ran me and you down, it's
like, we couldn't do anything.
Because even if you trade, you still knocked.
So, it's like, if you...
I also had a semi-auto weapon.
Yeah, but you know what I mean, though, right?
Yeah.
The only way for us to stop is to use Util or Nate.
Or if you get a knock, fucking toss a Fragorn Dale on top of
it.
Can we put this into...
Let's add AI to here.
What?
Let's practice with AI.
This is all you can do.
what yeah we also don't have the right nades equipped by the
way they use the wind nades smoke nades slow nades we need
to use like i think dragon and heal nade are the worst nades
i feel like every every team in this tournament is a
valorant team except for us we are yeah pretty much we are
not equipped with this we are not equipped for this i'm
starting this custom game we're practicing Some players are
not ready.
Maybe we should have done this before the tournament.
Yeah.
Looking at me like it's my fault.
You're the captain.
Like even if I said maybe you guys want to practice, you'd
be like, nah, I don't have the time to practice guys.
I played the game.
We are also a better defender team just because it requires
less coordination on the defense.
It's all about the frags.
But the thing is like we we got to capitalize on like Damage
like if we get a knock or something like we have to do
something even if I call flashes like if I flash someone
Just fucking go in please.
It's like if you go by one by one.
It's just i did that and I died by the
way Apparently we need the painter good girl.
She's called madalena I don't which one is that painter she
paints she's the one that keeps throwing the glue on the
ground Yeah, but like i don't know what i think her name is
madalena know what does she look like i think is it a
glasses girl i'm michelle mandalina or some shit what i
equipped uh i've i've equipped a wind grenade and a slow
grenade i feel like they fucked us with those oh i forgot a
telltale grenade what is the telltale grenade when grenade
is just like to slow down pushes so it's really good for i
think it i think it tells oh is it like a scouter maybe i
guess we just practice utils okay apparently the the
madalena is a dmr that has goo that slows everyone and she's
opus fuck that's what chad's telling me and chad's always
okay so who's gonna play her who is the player i want to do
sorry girl more not me it's not being sure for is well it's
a i mean i can swap i can play the goo girl like we just
won't have here trying on my slow night i mean i just feel
like snipers work in this game i mean these are bots though
yeah but we're all we got what we got them up wow what we
got are executing they're executing who and how who's
throwing nades where that's literally all we gotta figure
out and knock out we're doing it against the bots
oh there's also there's also an interceptor nade which
apparently uh that nade uh blocks all other nades it's like
okay so that's what we need for attacks basically oh okay
yeah interceptor it's also good for defense too because they
execute with flash and smokes oh stuff like that okay i'm
just like you guys to do all the grenade stuff my brain is
too small for that i know how to use my abilities frag
grenade is only good if we get a knock to finish from
distance now i feel like fragment that's why i'll be i'll be
the frag grenade to make sure we get our knocks i feel like
i set the difficulties of this ai to piss large something.
I'm pretty sure.
I mean, it's AI.
AI is always not good.
Don't say that.
I played against AI in ranked and they were crazy.
You don't even know which one's an AI and which one is it?
Yeah, you do.
By the names.
What would the names be?
It's like two words in the world like capitalize.
Like celestial wind or some shit.
I think I think wait can i end this much uh and we can make
ai harder all right surrender i can't believe that we're
surrendering to ai we're practicing this is in the name of
practice apparently these are level one ai's okay well can
we surrender it said in the next round it will
and then just kill all of them.
I'm just going to bone rush.
Oh, yeah.
The wallhack that Next has is only for your Next, by the
way.
Yeah, yeah.
I know.
That's why I always call it out if, like, I see people on
that.
They're all made up here.
We should kill all of them so we can surrender.
We should use Next as our, like, our little scouter.
Yeah, yeah.
Dude, by the way, that's my one.
It is so fucking annoying.
That's my one neighbor.
It's so annoying.
It's okay.
I just need it.
It's fine.
Here's a slow nade too, guys.
Oh, the slow nade doesn't slow us.
It's just them.
Yeah, it should.
Yeah.
Makes sense.
Okay, I think we literally just lost on fucking nades when
you think about it.
Yeah, 100%.
Wait, I thought we were...
Oh, there you go.
All right.
Wait, how do you ping in this game?
Z.
It's Z.
We were winning
Team MVP She's crying All right here AI difficulty super AI
Holy shit That's the rank AI you've been fighting all along
Guys I feel like we should we should uh We should practice
attack because we suck an attack Let's go attack Okay
Trifor come to attack.
He wants to play with the pot set.
I think he's AFK.
I'll practice defend.
This is going to help our team coordination, Trifor.
We need to.
There we go.
Fuck.
I tried to swap.
Imagine you just...
but we're trying to practice this guy's just taking us down
one by one we're like that's human element is this oh
madalina okay i see madalina what am i what am i playing
here again i was playing what do i get to get rid of the
other sure for took my character bro what was your character
uh this one married it she's hot so i'll play her what the
it's all about team comp it's not about the hotness right
now Scan knife.
Okay, I'll play the scan knife, bitch.
Fine.
She's got a fat ass too.
What?
She's got the KO knife.
Wait, don't take frag grenade.
Slow grenade.
Oh, I fucked up.
I fucked up.
I forgot to swap my util because you have to do it every
time.
I have a sniper rifle.
Oh, you went for Kanami?
She's good.
I like her.
Why did you say it like that?
Yeah, it's a little creepy.
weird that's a little creepy okay how do we so how are we
coordinating this but the bots won't use nays though so like
what are we gonna practice i guess our aim true okay but we
can at least talk about like what we want to do you know and
set up like a remote plan like a default i will shoot my my
recon shorts and uh maybe shoot someone in head okay i will
just go like look She's over there.
Whoa.
Guys, I just scanned on point.
She's got a turret.
What the fuck?
Yeah, that box got a turret.
Oh my god, they're doing movement stuff.
I missed everybody.
Guys, these bots are crazy.
These stream mid.
What the fuck?
You got destroyed.
These bots are crazy.
Guys, so we didn't practice the take at all.
Oh shit.
Okay, you're right.
You're right.
crazy the head shouldn't the head sure you're right these
bots are crazy they're once coming back oh wait not this
sniper sucks in this game i can't tell if it's hit scanner
projectile
I think we need to find someone for sure for that they can
play.
No, I can play once.
I don't know how to play.
I like the DMR characters, but they just suck at close
range.
DMR characters are good, apparently, because they have good
abilities.
Yeah, but they just suck at close range.
So what do you want to play?
whatever so play dmr then whatever wait that was the plan
even with the shift what when you shift well they just don't
shoot us that's why well it's they also have spread when you
shift what are these ai thinking dude the absolute best no
one's up there no one's up there a's clear i got a i'm
pushing mid i'm pushing mid I'm moving to whoa I'm sorry I
missed every shot I fuck him up I fuck up the I'm whizzing
I'm whizzing I'm whizzing okay that one down we got the res
I am planting I'm getting flanked is someone holding not
good not good I'm holding high ground for you I think they
raised the guy killed holy shit they can do that yeah the
bots are strong oh my gosh I see them They're low as fuck.
Oh my god.
Two on next.
Down one.
Down one of the bots.
Whoa!
Here.
Last guy's here.
Swear.
He's resing.
Like one HP.
Yeah.
Oh my god.
I've been fucking with the DMR.
We're winning against bots.
I'm so proud of us.
Maybe DMR is the play.
Oh my god.
Look at my skin.
Just look behind me.
i'm not gonna look i will not look you got paid me to look
in your pervertedness you should look you need to pay me to
look uh let's go a a i'm gonna pay you to look at this we
were all heading to b we were all heading to b no i'm in b
i'm in b i'm in b i'm in b i'm in b oh my god i'm already at
a i'm gonna i'm gonna i'm gonna knife mid let's go mid he's
got the turret just shoot them oh wait there's one more one
more there's one on the high ground i'm shooting a donkey
bird i'm shooting a donkey bird i'm just 7-2 on him i mean
this thing actually doesn't fucking work crawling i'm
crawling wait look at my oh my god whoa i need help should
they rest there i'm resting i'm resting too help me okay
give me a sec
important I'm resing was that important I fucking used that
need to save your life oh never mind I did not save my own
life I literally res you I okay I'm not resing this guy
again
why should I res you this is a fucking AI match because you
would have lost without me though lavin creates a stealth
zone and becomes invisible you're literally bottom bragging
dude i can go invisible in this yeah look at look at yeah
look at this angle run behind me follow me follow me where
oh yeah do you see it
dude the skirt is going up you see our cheeks is crazy guys
i got demolished but i ain't but turn in the panning smoking
my thinking is going over i've hit them i hit them holy
that's a lot of people oh my god planting planting there's a
lot of people there doing in my goose nice i'm okay i'm
gonna do another i'm coming there big come Huh?
All three are there.
They're low.
Oh, but I got a dog.
Oh, I got a dog.
That's low.
One.
Oh, high ground.
They're all one HP.
And I got flashed.
Okay, the paint lady is kind of strong.
Okay, this lady is insane.
Yes.
You can't flash team.
teammates or can you fly you can I can flash me the one game
yeah you can you can 100 flash teammates wait this this did
you just like not trust me or like what's the problem here
who are you telling that to I was just reconfirming what you
said because someone else oh sure for why don't you trust
our PR our PR is a victim victim right now i am i literally
am a victim right now what the it's not even me don't worry
about it like victim complex no there's no victim complex at
all i'm flying what the why did you guys win grenade in
yourself oh there's people on me all three all three are
here i'm with you i'm with you okay there was a sniper over
there I'm dead.
Might need it or no.
Guys, bro, what the fuck are you doing?
Yeah, but they're all dying.
You didn't say it was more than one!
I said they were all down there!
Why is he losing to AI, you fucking disgraces?
It's fine.
We'll save this shit.
Don't worry, I got it.
Oh my god.
I got it.
Headshots.
All headshots.
Guys, shoot the little turrets as well.
Like, what are we doing?
I think we're ready, guys.
None of us are taking this.
Seriously, right now it gets the AI match.
We're just fraggy.
We're just practicing our A.
We're not even practicing teamwork.
No, we're practicing something.
Something's being practiced.
Like, this character is good.
We should do an A execute.
A through mid, out IV through connector.
Wait, who has a smoke?
RPH, you're not, you're not shot caller.
I don't know.
Do you know how to smoke that like fast?
Figure out that out.
I don't know what smoke.
I feel like we shouldn't go like actual I'm blind I should
go mid wait next what do you say yeah yeah mid seems like a
good play Yeah, but I feel like we're not gonna be on this
map.
We're gonna be on a different map Well another map
She's aim body.
I'm free rest My god, there's like turrets here.
I'm free rest.
Yeah you want to say that again oh yeah what a useless
teammate oh yeah like the time you did it res me are they it
was the it was the end of the round doesn't matter you
didn't res you got this here for i believe in you i believe
in the bullet went through them he healed he healed the
snipers
Yeah, I think he's off the stage, man.
At least he looks pretty.
Hey, at least now you know you won't play this character
Everyone saw that right that car sir was on that bit at
least we know you won't play this character in the side It
looks straight up.
It's all the arrow Oh,
there you go there you go you're giving
Bro, swall the whiff.
We got hit.
Everyone's seen that shit, right?
That shit's going through them.
Bro, you have another gun.
Why don't you get your other gun?
Because I'm trying to see how this bullshit gun works, but
half the time these bullets just morph through these
motherfuckers.
So bad.
Let's do a, let's do something.
whatever.
I give up.
I give up mid talk, bro.
I'm over it.
How many more minutes till our next match?
Nine, nine minutes.
Nine minutes.
Yippee.
Sova Arrow going out.
She's on the turret again.
It's a bot.
She'll always be on the turret.
I slowly.
How is she so good at movement?
a code the code's better than us there's no oh there's a guy
right here hello yeah I trusted you don't hold me all right
87 don't trust anyone not even yourself my grenades there
next if you get hit by it's your fault okay I don't think
you actually is it not wait we should experiment see if
nades hurt each other like the frag grenades all right who
wants to test mine okay i'll test it no you can't you can't
reach over to those things with frag grenades i know you can
flash each other yeah i don't think you can do team damage
in any form oh okay that's great throwing myself i'm just
gonna test it now yeah it needs to be tested just to be sure
me then just to be sure i only i only listen to level 30 I'm
all the five.
That's why we're not listening to you.
There's a goose low.
Oh.
Your own nades do hurt you.
It does.
Yeah, but they don't hurt me.
Okay, wait, does it hurt?
Okay, wait, wait.
Next face, uh, I'm going to throw my nade on you.
Oh, okay.
We just tried it.
I took zero damage.
Oh, yeah.
No one ever trusts me, bro.
You're not level 30.
He's not level 30.
What were we doing about?
We're confirming for each other.
I threw that nade.
Yeah, yeah.
I got a donkey bull shooting on me.
It's a donkey bull shooting.
She is that, but I'm definitely...
I can get up.
Res two...
Oh, wait.
You have that.
Yeah, yeah.
March is fine.
Dude, we got this easy.
Yeah, I mean, I bought this again.
And that was really fun.
Now I'm cat girl.
okay so what oh i need to swap my util i keep forgetting
that okay so what do we what grenade do we need you need the
wind wind storm and slow grenade apparently okay can i put
so healing grenade doesn't matter okay intercept grenade is
also good if you want like uh club what's on basically all
right i got i'll do interceptor and wind wind grenade it's
good like if they want to throw smokes on site you just
throw that shit and just delete stole the smokes when they
throw them before or after before before it's like watson
jen ah big a boob all right how you figure out what what
character you want to play now cheer for playing the guy
with dmr because i think after this game we have to we're
going to the next match right i play yeah you want to play
let's
but see a more anime you want to play let's play okay no
we're going to do that
bro oh my god they're mid I killed one I killed one I killed
one he said you said do it more anime
I did say that I won't practice my Yeah, I won't practice my
Diga Yeah, one guy mid very low There you go Right here Very
low He's aiming at me Guys, look at the ping On IPN Oh, it's
IPN's ping 160 words Paper, I can't hit them Oh, shit Oh,
yeah, we also need to use paper more guys Yeah, I am Oh, wow
I'm gonna use less paper I did not just what you do that
that was terrible I heard use more paper so I used I just
listened to my ITL so you jumped into an aid yeah to my ITL
I was like more paper the papers into an aid got it guys did
not specify anything do i have to tell you not to die yes
yes stay alive i didn't see the grenade nobody said anything
about the grenade i didn't see it indicator all right it's
everyone's fault but yours is that how life is yep i'm the
main character i've been spotted it's a guys use your you're
just good not this You got shot by Yeah, I got shot by sure.
I got shot by three of them.
I got shot by three of them, bro I gotta raise you here
you're gonna come out you die Oh, we're gonna push What What
would right set to no, these guys are way better at
executing than they are they're they're not even talking to
each other they actually like push as a team and shit
what is that like having a team what is that like three men
pushed at the same time that's crazy there's a lot we can
learn from these bots man why don't we why don't we work
together as team i don't understand i don't like we all play
team games overwatch is a team game why don't we why don't
we work i blame you well you see they three men they three
men swung my ass we should do that also by the way that's
the best way to win fight is to swing with as many numbers
as possible i didn't set my turrets i forgot to i'm gonna do
it next don't die they're not oh there's oh yeah it is b it
is b guys oh don't worry i have my inter oh he's dead okay
he's dead i have my interceptor how far is oh oh someone
went mid they went mid it was not just b but also mid she's
flying she's flying over here over here i ping them i can't
i I fucking know are you fucking why do you have a normal
maid why do you have a normal maid but they're flying whoa
oh we won we won wow we said two more rounds guys we still
have two more rounds guys
wait isn't our mess starting uh after this the admin said
they're gonna they're gonna come pick us up yeah they know
we're special in the head so yeah okay i'm very smart who
are we fighting against next scheme what are we fighting for
will they be easier or harder i can't believe i can't
believe we even won our first round to be fair i saw that in
the trend one of some of the players are like top 100
valorant players guys so are we okay we have we have four x
pro players in this team don't even play valorant that don't
even play valorant
what's how many seasons does valorant have they're on a
they're on a guys yeah me too are they already in i'm
holding i'm telling you one I killed him but yeah we got one
kill too on our end I'm heading over here whoa be careful
whoa is this our all pushing I think I'm a freak I don't
know where they're gonna come from oh I'm yeah I'm me I'm me
I'm me I'm me I hope he knocks you this is my win grenade me
next to him last is the We can't lose to the sniper because
sniper is useless.
True or true.
My wind grenade killed me.
Staff is useless, right?
Yes.
I pushed the sniper and I was stuck in a wind grenade.
Go up here, go.
I'm waiting.
Go RPR, you're doing it.
You guys are doing it.
What does this do?
What is that all?
She like pulls you in and like makes you die.
Oh, guys, one last game before we play a real game.
oh no why oh no i don't think nex believes in us guys i
don't think he believes in us honestly can i even blame him
at this point you literally made this team all i'm saying is
i'm top damn in this bot match oh my god top damage top
damage i think we know who's not the problem I feel like an
old wash charm that's like being the deepest guys I have max
damage yeah I'm gold medals they're coming they're coming in
they're coming in whoa they are I'm smoking oh my through my
turret this is their killjoy all right are you guys okay
over there there's a killjoy
one oh hey my turrets beaming him oh okay i did not see that
guy yeah
this is a good game we're not playing the same map already
no and each map is different each match because i found some
nice play again to goof you're so good so good at this bot
thank you look at me second second to mvp second to mvp look
at me guys not the wow against the look at the last place
donkey bird problem think about it this way those bots have
aimbot i'm better than me i'm giving you know what sure for
i'm gonna give you a like over here thank you thank you hey
hello is everyone doing we're just one of our games these
guys are all depressed that is nice okay so current
situation uh the current game that is handling right now is
going in a bit over time so we will so they started they
started hella late is what you're saying they didn't they
did start hella late and then they also really really close
right now the game is really really close how did they do
that how are they going so close i don't know it is seven
yeah ours was so fast how come how well that's because they
started hell and late they started about set about like
eight minutes late so yeah wasn't there a penalty for like
if they're late look i remember that i read the rules okay
one of the teams one of the teams is called skippity risler
i read those rules you guys are like we will penalize teams
that are late
i can't do nothing about that okay the names are fucked as
it is Okay, but listen, if you don't disqualify, we're gonna
blame you Wait, I like how you censor yourself, but we're
all like fucking swearing already.
So yeah We all heard fuck So like it doesn't matter because
they have to censor it anyway I have a plug-in that auto
censors mine.
Oh, no way.
That's so if I just like regular talking I go fuck shit
Wait, what?
No way.
How do you do that?
So That's insane.
That's crazy.
We got to stay family friendly for the Twitch viewers, you
know?
Wait, you can do that?
Yeah, you can do that?
We need that.
Lord knows I need that.
Don't get demonetized for swearing.
Yeah, no, no, no demonetization here.
I need to get my ad sense.
It's okay.
We'll swear for you.
So your editors will have to edit our censors for us.
Wait, I'm not allowed to swear?
No, you're allowed to be passionate, sure, for us.
say anything you okay no actually don't say anything you
ever want to say actually do not you need limiters you mean
I need limiters say everything that you want listen guys if
I had that bleep function my stream would literally be
this we just we just send Morse code you know Fuck you!
I need a translator.
Alright, so I will get you guys ready for the next match.
The code should be ready.
Looks like...
You can't show it on stream, right?
I'm gonna go take a piss.
Okay, the game has just concluded.
Yay!
Dragged him over to our game now.
How do you make a custom match?
You just have to leave on the bottom right.
Are we facing the winning team or the losing team?
team you guys are facing the winning team oh guys it's okay
this is round robin day so like it doesn't matter because
right wait they're gonna be over confident coming from a win
and that's who we're gonna get him yeah this is the round
robin round robin day if these guys started eight minutes
late and it lasted that long that means these guys are
waiting until there's like 30 seconds we can execute every
round oh waiters they're gonna be cringe so aggressiveness
might be good against them because they're not gonna expect
like to get fun dumb asses to just run in yeah i gotta we
gotta hide screen and you don't show this we're so we're
dumb if you're yourself i'm smart if you're so smart why are
we losing
fucking it's this idiot uh if we show as the bot game show
wait these are it's these guys play valorant so much i'm
gonna go pee right back wait we'll play against actual
valorant players all right you guys all joining yeah man
yeah all right no technical issues we're missing two people
because they went to the bathroom okay so uh for you guys
you guys get or tails the captain's not always heads but i
choose heads okay you guys picked heads give me a one quick
second you
guys have lost sadly no we lost again it's okay we're used
to it yeah we're used to it now let me get the other teams
pick and then i'll relay the information to you guys on
defense or attack all right hey guys they're gonna pick
defense guys I don't I'm not I'm not as confident anymore at
this point just have fun you guys sound like doomers right
says you like hello what do you mean says me I'm you're just
tone of voice is always hey that's just you guys are
defending so make sure you guys are playing on team be all
right yeah we're team b yay let's go these guys are gonna
attack us yeah these guys are gonna fuck us up it's it's
over you're gonna get in the ass real badly okay like real
even the admin doesn't believe in us like this is so they
are just reaffirming what you're saying
Admin doesn't believe in us.
I believe in you guys, okay.
Thank you, Admin.
I don't trust you.
Guys, nades, nades, nades, nades.
Oh, nades, nades.
Take the right nades.
Who do I play?
Play the guy that goes boom with the DMR.
Oh, man.
What do you mean, oh, man?
I mean, die someone else there.
What do you want?
You want to play?
Let's play.
Can't believe it.
did you find out how to tp yeah okay nice this is a dust two
mat this team is the most content if there's there's
actually king's row in this game wait there's king's row i
all i'm saying okay listen all i'm saying if this game mode
for the tournament was escort we would be winning by a mile
right guys true sure guys they would actually they'd be
getting shit on no cap what map is this oh I remember this
yeah I put this is this is dust yeah yeah yeah like we're on
dust how do we how do we everyone knows the callouts on dust
yeah I know I see it this is fucking long A yeah you hold
this from up here from up here sure for Wait, I should
hold...
Someone should hold mid.
Okay, I'll...
I'll...
I'll do something on bars, but I'm scared.
I'll hold mid, then.
I don't know how this map works, bro.
I don't know.
This is dust, bro.
Use your nades, use your nades!
They're top as well.
They can drop down on us on high ground.
Use your nades, not your aim.
Oh, I got flash!
I'm blind!
Did I throw my nade?
I don't know if I threw it correctly.
They won't.
They won't?
Yeah, yeah.
I got them flying up there.
One drop, two, three, four, four.
dropping what the fuck they can do oh they got me guys they
are very coordinated too that these guys are way too horny i
got one i got one get one more i'm thirsty for more there's
four more there's four more there's four more guys we can
see for next round right below you right below you good mate
get an ace get an ace i believe oh you i i stopped believing
no no no how did he come from bro okay okay i i held like
dust tube but the thing is there's a high ground whoever
said yeah i didn't know that yeah i didn't know they can
draw from height yeah no high ground's cheating okay also
these guys are very very coordinated like they win me i mean
they're literally valor players Hello!
Like, we're gonna do the actual Valor players!
Hey!
Just fucking shoot them!
Stop complaining!
Sure, if her plays alone on A, you guys stuck three on B.
I play mid-rotation.
Oh, it's because I'm the bot.
I'm the bot champion.
I get it.
The bot champion.
They're going B!
Okay, I'm coming over.
I'm coming over.
They already found the weak site.
You know what I mean?
W shutdown It might be a bait It might be a bait It might be
a bait I'm checking I'm checking mid again These guys think
it's Valorant Bro It is Yeah they're executing A they're
executing A long Careful lurkers though I forgot my shit
Wasn't auto anymore Guys this is really bad I'm behind them
Oh they saw me They saw me in high wors below you surfer on
the stairs okay i'm safe i got out they planted on the roof
top left on the roof knocked one knocked one there one shot
out there first thing i knocked one number nice on top of me
one shot one shot on my bed one shot it's fine it's fine
it's fine it's fine we got him i got him got him now one
more top one more top one more top one shot our top one shot
oh There's no way he win-grenaded me.
He waited with the excuse to win-grenade.
These guys are nerds.
That guy's so lucky he killed me.
It's okay guys, we got him figured out now.
Guys, we're slowly building teamwork.
Very slowly.
We called that fake from a mile away.
That was obvious.
Success.
I'll go.
I'll look at mid.
Look at bottom.
Hope for them.
Wait.
We don't have hope.
We have bottom mid.
What's you looking at me for?
It's not me.
I see guy mid.
I see a guy mid.
Yeah.
They're all top.
They're all tiger out mid.
They're not bottom mid.
Top mid.
Top mid all of them.
They're going to come at me.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
They're...
He's fucking sees me on the paper Mario shit.
He's above.
He's above me.
I think they're going A.
I don't know.
What is up?
What the fuck is above you?
They're rotating B.
Rotating B.
They're rotating.
They're all rotating.
That angle's crazy.
That's a cheating angle.
They're chasing me down mid.
They're looking at me at mid as well.
Oh, God.
They're actually going to be.
Okay.
Hi.
No.
Oh, they traded.
okay oh he's already hot my ass oh i quit we got one guys
guys we're getting a little better right guys are we getting
a little better this is attack sighted guys yeah that's what
you said but last game no no this one is definitely attack
guys guys how about we push them somewhere as a
push b okay i can't push us if we're pushing okay you should
scan the you she's gonna why would they scan if they're
pushing yeah yeah they're not gonna extra villager some
pussy i'm throwing one deep what here they're waiting for me
They keep scanning.
They might rotate.
They might rotate because of...
Yeah, because they know that we're all there now.
Yeah, they're valve players, dude.
They have intel.
I don't see anybody, man.
What a sick mate.
Oh, they're still waiting for next.
Bro!
No!
Next!
Wait, wait, wait.
You can kill him.
I'm going to ult and kill him.
Okay.
I got his ass.
I thirsted.
Nice first.
I ulted as well.
Not looking at...
Someone just wants Sharifor, I think?
Yeah, they ulted.
I see a blue ult there.
He's KO'd.
Wait, someone's top.
I can't fight that one.
Oh, one of them is invisible.
Oh, I got spotted.
I got spotted.
They got blue shit.
You know?
How the fuck do they know?
Ghost me.
Cheaters, man.
Fucking putting up my turret.
On my side, Sharifor.
Behind you, Sharifor.
Oh, they can't shoot through the wall.
Cheating.
Oh, no.
Why am I slowed?
It's not fair.
They have a full auto gun.
You scared the shit out of me.
No full auto in close quarters.
No full auto inside the building.
Oh no.
We are fucked.
We're doing so good.
I thought you said no doomers.
I'm not dooming anymore.
No, this is attack sided guys.
doing anymore you know how we're you know why we fucked why
because i'm top fracking that's bad yeah true i keep buying
by one hey hey i have i have 297 damage yeah he hasn't done
that's ping i know that's yeah and you also only have 297
damage yeah your damage is role-playing your ping right now
bro hey learn to swing use your ping advantage yeah Yeah,
where's your ping advantage?
I'm a professional swinger.
They're going A, they're going A.
I'm heading over there.
A, A, A!
I got them flying, I got the tornadoes on them.
Are you okay?
Okay, I got one.
I got one.
Nice.
Okay, I'm looking at mid, I'm looking at mid with you.
They fell back.
Oh, next, no!
They are gonna res.
No!
That's so dumb.
Oh, they're all gonna rush me.
They're gonna rush me so bad.
i knew it oh i last forever i got time so hard they're top
mid they're all hack bullshit ass game why do i don't really
have a gun like when they rush me with an auto gun it's okay
i'm watching sure for it not frigo oh my god he has the
better he has the better fucking dmr i think this emo thing
on my body has dubbed like Tab!
Look at my ping!
Or Sink is like, heart-carrying.
Fucking nerd.
It's not fair.
He plays with Shroud.
He knows how to do this.
There's no way!
No.
This game is so fun!
attack is just easier trust me guys oh my god there's a need
up there already what the fuck trust me guys i went to
school oh bb yeah yeah yeah guys don't be afraid to pull
back oh i got exposed tracks on there yeah we're pulling
back already oh i'm gonna look at mid just in case they're
pushing right side they're pushing right side
I gave that guy brain massage.
I'm dead.
Resonance.
Okay.
Oh, I got wind-grenaded.
My aim is...
Oh, he's up here.
I'm covering.
I'm covering for you over here.
I'm covering to your left.
I think they're going to push.
I think they're feeling confident.
Yeah.
Yeah, I got knocked.
I got knocked one.
Two, the behind her.
Put me to the edge.
Don't worry.
She's for...
I believe.
You should never rely.
You got this.
Yes, I'll always be my...
audio audio audio that's an audio issue
i still believe in us come on man we gotta lock b down man
bro our b is not great our b is not good and they just none
of our shit is good wait does that mean we're gonna fight
the team that like like they like won against because like
that team almost won against them too so can we not talk I
feel like they placed us in the wrong bracket we should now
be been in this bracket there's like another bracket where
there's no valor players there's osu players it's a
Schufer's gonna die again they did the most stupid fucking
knife imaginable all I'm saying is that No, that is the
first time I pushed that angle.
Wait, what is mid?
How did he come from mid?
That KO knife is bullshit.
Nah, I'm telling you, there seems to have been these guys.
They know I'm here because I peaked.
Oh, he's looking at me.
Wait, are you guys okay?
Up there, up there, up there.
Guys, I don't think you're okay.
Maybe I'll just save my gun.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I got my kill!
I got the whole gang on me!
Let's go!
Get shit on!
Pussy!
Who does shit on?
ZK, who the fuck is ZK?
I don't know, you got shit on.
Congratulations, you got your first kill.
That was my second kill, dumbass.
But I didn't get the finish.
That was my second kill, I didn't get the finish.
I'm playing on 300 ping!
be carrying me.
That's your choice.
You literally.
No, this server is fucked.
My rules.
This server is fucked.
I literally see it go up in real time.
You recorded this.
You recruited this team.
I made a mistake.
Well, we're having fun.
Yeah, we're having so much.
Oh, it's me.
It's me.
Yeah, there's people in mid too.
They're mid.
They're mid as well.
They saw me.
I'm dead.
I've been spotted as well.
There's so many!
I pin you're so fucked.
Oh yeah, I am just getting lagged.
I just lagged out completely.
I'm with you.
Oh, he's on the walls.
He's climbing walls.
I don't see him behind me.
Behind me!
Bottom mid, bottom mid in our spawn.
Bottom mid in our spawn.
Oh my god, he...
Wait, that guy shot by two angles?
What the fuck was that?
I just deleted so fast.
You got res?
Yeah, yeah, that's her all.
1v3.
1v2 station.
Yeah.
Why is Trevor always in a situation where it's a 1v3?
I don't know, because I actually survive on my site.
Because he's playing B on dust.
He's playing B on dust.
Like, of course he's alone.
He's always retaking.
They built a wall!
We're trying to keep him out!
You guys are going to get 9-0 They took your sight without
even losing Whoa Nades, Nades, guys Pick the right Nades
Guys, we're going to get 9-0, man Whose fault is that?
The captain?
I was top fragger there Yeah, my bad for picking you guys
Honestly, yeah, you could have got any I could be preparing
for my debut right now You guys we're mentally preparing
right now.
Yeah, true.
You guys did good.
I give you a round of applause It's because our admin didn't
believe in us.
So I went in with doomer mentality because my admin didn't
believe in us Like you were doomer from the start.
No, that's not true.
That was not true.
It's still winnable because Can we get one point?
Let's get one point, guys.
I believe that you can win, okay?
I don't trust anything you say.
The comeback is real.
Right here.
God, she's hot.
Why can't we play against Osu players?
We did play against Osu players.
Did we?
And we lost?
We lost the Osu player.
Yeah, you see like a champion?
Yeah, but isn't it valid players in that Osu team?
Wait, this guy's just pushing me.
Top midair.
Good shoot on!
Thirst him.
Just remember the third.
Yeah, this gun.
I already did.
There's one bottom left.
Bottom left.
Of me.
I'm looking, but I'm not seeing.
Oh, they're pushing me again.
One right here.
Oh my god.
Okay.
Guys, you're all just sitting there.
They're pushing.
What did I just die to?
I got.
I got sniped.
Ethos, you fucking nerd.
Oh, I got flash.
Goodbye.
This fucking nerd sniping in defense.
I mean, Truffle was sniping in defense.
Only on the bot matches.
He was DMRing defense.
I'm looking at flanks right now.
Next has this.
I'm watching you next.
I'm looking at flank right here.
What are we doing B?
Two in middle.
Okay, I'm coming over.
I'm coming over.
Oh my god.
I don't know, man.
One died.
I'm lucky.
It's like a wash in a bunch of be chickens with their heads.
Shut the fuck up.
I can't play like that.
Use your cue, dokey.
I'm fucking using your cue, dokey.
Kill her!
No.
That was close.
I'm flanking now because of me!
Now my character is sad because of you guys!
Fragger.
I got second.
You know what?
There's a pattern.
Shrefor and I are always sharing, like, top and second.
I don't know.
Anyone else break 2K?
Didn't think so.
The fact that, like, you know... The fact that I have 2,000
damage when more than half the time they didn't even come to
my site and I have to retake one before, that's crazy.
That's crazy.
I don't even... I don't even break 1k i'm playing with 300
to listen to your voice the entire time i have my utility
out more than like my gun and i'm third how i have a grenade
launcher that shoots slows more than i'm like explain i was
throwing nage the entire game so was ipn i hate that when i
was doing it right i hate that when it's time also i'm on
300 ping half of my damage doesn't register oh now you now
he's using ping as an excuse i said from the start out 300
ping did you not hear me last match i had 200 that's
playable 300 is not playable wait but you got why did you
get invited as a captain then knowing that you you're gonna
get 300 ping oh wow i wasn't told that there's gonna be na
and jp only but also i was told there's only players in this
tournament car you straight up fucking lie to me apex pro by
the way previously
yep he's not helping us yeah we got the third one for sure
okay yeah yeah you know what next is like our like emotional
support player right now he's here i'm telling you group a
just isn't ours group b however when We fight any of those
guys?
It's Joe over.
You're like, why are we in group A?
Why the fuck are we there?
If we win our last match, can we still go through?
No, this is round, Robin.
Second day we fight.
I'm not round.
One day, this is where we're figuring out our points.
Wait, so wait, this doesn't matter.
This doesn't matter.
You play proceeding.
Oh, let's go.
Yeah, we're playing proceeding.
Oh, but then we're throwing on purpose.
No, because if we...
Because then people in the better seedings...
Wouldn't the people in the better seedings fight us?
Because they...
Yeah!
That's the whole point.
Because if we don't get to fight the B group, we have to
fight these guys again.
We gotta win one.
If we lock in the less ground, it's easy.
If we win at least one, we get to fight somebody in group B.
in lock in lock in last match lock in the last please i
could be prepping my debut right now you have 30 minutes i
mean yeah you can do it right now yeah prep right now what
do you mean i can't fucking change my scenes right now guys
you should i'm not gonna debut on a strenova you should you
should all watch docis uh debut because i voice acted in it
oh yeah he has forest lands in there i do yeah no spoilers
i'm a voice actor by the way thanks i'm not gonna let you
and then yeah he's not i don't think next cares i don't
think he cares
the voice i'm not gonna spoil but it's a really good one how
long how long is our next game is this 30 minutes again yep
you have another 30 minute break your next game starts at 3
p.m pst like are they are they playing right now or are they
almost done they are they have yet to start this they
haven't even started it's because guys what do you not
understand they're expecting every match every i do have to
say this i do have to say this though i have to announce
this so as you guys probably know uh we actually have a
substitute player so our practice didn't really matter you
know yeah our main player yeah our member was supposed to be
raffle gator way better than next at the overwatch way
better wait we could have done worse than how could we do
worse how do we get four rounds the one game that's because
i i don't know like we weren't tainted and booming get
better we were just like we we cared more and now i'm a
consistent player me too hey me too i play the same whether
i'm tilted sad happy or mad i'm happy even though i was
still second fragger similar to our first game i was second
fragger no yes i was i remember because i was happy about
that i was like the one that was the only time was happy
during that game you're you're counting starts from the game
when we lost zero nine yeah no i'm counting stats from my
first game and so you can't judge me for counting stats on
the zero and that was sure for was yelling about being top
fragger there yeah he was yelling but no one cared oh oh so
you guys don't care about him but you care about me that's
up mvp
Yeah, that was MVP, bro.
MVP on the first and second.
I should go and catch and start flaming him.
Oh, shit.
Oh, okay.
I thought you actually went.
I was like, yeah.
He put a black little square over our name.
Oh, because of our name.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah, by the way, guys.
So our name, team name is Overwatch 2, but legally they
couldn't do that but yeah so we're watch over now so they
had to put up i mean they could have done they could told us
not to use that name but then they committed to it and now
they said legally they can't do that so they have to like i
also want to point out that that was docky's idea the
illegal literally rpr was like hey can you give me a name
give you know i could have asked any other teammate for
names like he did not have to put my suggestion as a name i
thought you were like intelligent or something
anyway so yeah now our name is censored on the mainstream
yeah but then you could have been a pussy yeah should have
been a pussy then you should be careful with your words in
the future i think don't use those words because you know
how it guys i don't think i'm going to be invited to a next
true nova thing guys i think it might be blacklisted it's a
true nova i mean it's true nova admin's trying to make it
sound like you will you won't you won't i'm i mean i mean no
it's not no they're not inviting her that's happening that
i'll say um listen i'm now admin we're not inviting you
don't keep it wait what's happening You don't get to hear.
Depending on your schedule, I'd like to especially talk with
you to RPR and Doki after probably tonight.
Why her?
What?
Am I in trouble?
No, I wouldn't say you're in trouble.
I wouldn't say you're in trouble.
Are we going to the principal's office?
No, what did I?
She made me do it.
He's literally the captain.
should be responsible for the entire safety game i will lick
dms that is that is the big thing though as the captain you
gotta remember you're upholding the rest of your team that
was your fault you should not have invited me why am i why
is like just me other people sure for also was also what but
we were good you're not the only one you're not the only
ones wait what i'm pulling i'm um we're pulling
approximately about eight to twelve other people for what
did we do what did we do what the you did it's nothing you
did it's nothing you did it's just a separate project that
is happening oh we're getting sponsored no we're not no
we're not perspective okay we are broke as okay uh i gotta
go somewhere later by the way oh so it's so we're not in
trouble we're not you are not in trouble you're in trouble
ducky i'm good rpr you represent the team you're in trouble
i get sponsored wait wait does that mean i can say whatever
i want and rpr gets in trouble yeah no no no no no no no no
i don't accept it i don't consent so wait so if we get last
place people will say rpr got last yeah true yeah yeah okay
let's lose guys it won't be me mvp svp svp yeah svp yeah svp
dk damage this just sounds tragic i i i At least, you know
what's sad?
The captain not breaking 1K.
I'm going to hang my mouse next game and let you do all the
work.
Bro, that's pretty much what you did last game.
That's all I'm saying.
What is up to the team, bro?
I hate the team.
Why do I even mind you guys?
You chose the team.
Do you know what's crazy?
ever again i was first pick for the team that was the first
person he asked to join this because you dm me because you
dm me and you were like you want to play the chain game next
to it i was like by the way you want to join street noah i
was literally first pick it's a night for a night type thing
i made a mistake but this is not a fun tournament though
right yeah i'm having a lot of fun guys but we're actually
in the game at least it's late in judgment we're on time i'm
punctual yeah yeah we were all punctual honestly i thought
doc is gonna be late tonight you guys don't get absolute
train railed tomorrow you can do that no maybe okay if you
if you want us to stay in We should make sure our opponents
are in.
No, what is this?
Shetty, listen, Shetty.
You said you're broke, right?
You need the viewership.
Yeah, come on.
Come on.
Dude, you want the viewership?
Listen, we might not be the best team, but we bring in the
content.
You want to keep us in this tournament as long as you can.
That's true.
Okay, I'm going to...
I better check on my bank account statement tomorrow, and it
just randomly shows plus 5K, and then I'll be like, Why me?
All I'm saying is that...
I have the highest viewership for Shre-Nova right now.
And if you want us to stay in the tournament longer...
What is the use of it?
This is blackmail, by the way.
This is blackmail, but we are not afraid to use it.
But we are not afraid to use it!
We will blackmail Shre-Nova!
it's not blackmail i'm saying if we somehow stay longer in
the tournament oh my god tomorrow's youtube clip is gonna be
team watch over blackmail strinoa i already see the title
man hey guys whatever happens i had a great time guys we're
not gonna get a cease in this no you're gonna get cease in
this is because you let this happen as the team captain yeah
you started the blackmail i'm just gonna no no i built on i
built on what you said you started the idea you planted the
seed you see what you did sherry oh what i did now hold up
wait a minute run that back you said i have responsibility
now they're stuck on this like it's true because it is true
an admin said it admin's word not responsible for your
actions and you notice i will not be guys how many more
minutes do we have left guys 20 minutes passed since we
argued we argued for only 10 minutes it's because we've done
this we've done this so many times already that we'd like
kind of speed run it now at this point we only argued for 10
minutes guys what can we talk about for 20 minutes i'm gonna
play a rank game we can't because the rank dispersity no why
did you guys do your place let's just play overwatch in
srenova we could we're all wait wait wait wait i gotta see
you do placements you do placements too wait wait shiri
tomorrow are we ever gonna play the escort we do not have
escort planned in this as a tournament That's our strong
game mode, by the way.
Currently at this time and standing, Escort is very, very,
very one-sided.
Yeah, it's heavily D-sided.
It's us-sided.
That's why they're not letting us play.
All right, guys, guys, let's play Escort right now to pass
the time, to at least feel something.
Like, feel like one win, you know?
Like, have one win in Tiff or today.
Wait, wait, is the custom game called RPR's Room?
yeah they win because they went into your room arp here and
i knowed you in your own house in my room they fucked us in
your own house that's so sad so that's because everyone left
so the title changed to rpr zoom no we oh yeah that's true
yeah the cost part of it all of them left our room tomorrow
i think the same time yeah oh god an hour later an hour
later actually later I'm gonna be so dead, man.
No way.
It's okay.
We'll get Raffle Gator to this place.
Okay, well.
Late arrivals will be penalized.
Where are the penalties?
I said that too!
Exploiting bugs or glitches will be prohibited.
What do you say next?
Rob has an even worse schedule than me.
Also, each team has 10 minutes after the said time to get
into the lobby.
So since the game starts at 00 and 30, respectively you have
up until 10 and 40 respectively too all right guys see you
in 30 minutes i have time where are you going it's like the
principal doesn't show up in 10 minutes you can leave you
want to start 10 minutes late and start at 3 10 and then
delay doki's uh yeah i'm leaving exactly at 3 30 that is you
know i'm just gonna leave the room and passed out for half
an hour That means I have the power.
The power to hold us hostage?
I will leave regardless if you're holding us hostage.
I'll have you know.
If someone wastes my time in league, I will hostage them.
If they feed their lane, I will hostage them.
All right, guys, come on.
Let's just play one escort, guys.
Just anything, please.
Fine.
Let us play escort.
Yay.
I ready.
I pee in.
I'm launching Among Us.
Who are you gonna play Among Us with?
Himself!
He's his worst enemy.
I'm gonna split my personalities.
His fucking...
Multi-box Among Us.
Oh my gosh, just like...
One of you is a beast.
Alright, let's do this, guys.
Let's win one game in our lives.
Surely we'll win.
Surely.
guys i believe in us there's no way
all right guys guys this is gonna be the day we win a game
no yeah this is it we're gonna win this game believe in us
we can't this is overwatch now yeah yeah this is overwatch
we're overwatch players hey guys we're against all bots
except for orion nixon Novarine.
There's no men in this game.
Wait, those are all bots, aren't they?
No, only two of them are not.
Two of them are real people, right?
What if they are?
What?
Let me ask them.
Are you real?
Yeah, type in team chat.
Yeah, I did.
Or, like, game chat.
Oh, hey, we're decided.
That means we're gonna win.
Yippee!
Yo, bots, question mark.
i think there are there's no real people anymore it's king's
row no it's not yes it is it is it's legally distinct king's
row guys it's queen's row it's queen's row did you just die
to a bot yeah they they are aim botting do not beat them
wait i can control my bear yeah yeah yeah yeah like a solver
though that's what they did to us remember yeah and then we
literally just looked at them that guy's in the air one hp
wait that's he's gonna turret oh he didn't die to a bot yet
once on the payload on the payload he's doing that dumb
cringe shit yeah i hate that shit i wish overwatch has that
i need a healing mercy we don't have mercy we don't have
mercy he has gotta live anyone got a pocket mercy or what
god no this is we just want to frag now what is that we have
grenades we have heal grenades just use that come to my heal
grenade i don't Yeah, I picked it up.
They're shooting Teddy Bear.
No.
No, not the Teddy Bear.
These bots ain't shit.
Because they're bots.
They're level one bots.
What do you mean?
Except next die to one of them.
No?
Yeah, I saw you dying.
It was a team kill.
Okay, well.
I just saw you die, huh?
All that smack talk for what?
You are in spawn.
You guys died to them, too.
I jumped off the map.
Wait, they're going to cap the first point.
They're not.
I'm here.
I'm active.
Oh, that was a huge need.
That was a huge need.
I'm going to throw a need, too.
I can't see.
There's a guy right up top.
I'm flashing him.
Watch out, don't get me.
No!
I didn't think you were flashing now!
I'm sorry!
Oh shit.
I avenged you!
I blame the guy that fucking flashing.
Two more seconds!
Oh my god, we have two more minutes!
Damn, next!
What?
Nothing.
Guys, we should have been playing this mode instead.
True.
To think.
RPR invited Apex and Overwatch players for a Valorant
portion of the game.
How was I supposed to know which game it was gonna be?
Because it was...
It's literally in the room.
I didn't read the rules!
Yeah, you tell now you didn't!
You didn't read the meter!
I did, I knew it was gonna be the Valorant, because I knew
it was gonna be the Valorant part.
You're a nerd.
Only nerds read.
Yeah.
And only... and nerds are winning.
The nerds are winning.
Wait, they're using nades, they're real people.
Ow, ow, ow.
Wait, some of them are actually...
Oh, the boss can use nades.
Oh, okay.
The bots use everything.
They're the goats.
Yeah, they're aimbotters.
All right.
We're doing it, guys.
They're going to cap.
We're not doing shit.
They cap.
See nine.
Bro, you guys are that bad.
Even in this game, we see nine.
Surefire, are you okay?
Does it bring PTSD?
I was dead.
Nothing I can do about it.
We're going to lose the bots.
No, we're not.
We're delaying this because we have fucking 10 more minutes.
Dude, look at me.
Look at where I'm moment king.
It's okay, guys.
Oh, on the point, on the point.
She's a everybody.
I mean, they're actually robots, so I'm going to fucking
throw my turret.
Fuck this.
I don't care.
They're beating.
Yay.
I'm getting cooked.
What's running?
What's that shit in this guy?
He's just beaming in...
Did you NAE flash me?
Did you fucking...
We're just spawn camping bots.
Oh, nice.
I'm so sure if I die an embarrassing death.
Next, I got you.
Fly high, bird.
I need some healing.
Oh!
Oh my god.
The amount of headshots I just delivered.
What does he want?
Oh, it is an eight.
Ow, fuck.
That's so funny.
I'm in here.
Paper marrowing.
Afia, you're literally like in there.
You're welcome.
I saved your life.
That's what teammates do to each other.
Not you.
The fuck?
What are they?
I'm killing them in spawn.
What do you mean?
Where are they?
How do they see Nynus?
Shoot that guy.
Shot him.
I got ace.
This should have been our game.
This should have been our game mode.
You're pushing C payload!
How the fuck is she pushing the payload?
I just killed everyone.
They're just going paper mode and like stay on it.
Yeah, they're just on paper mode and like fuck with us.
That's fucked up that they programmed that into the bot.
That's actually messed up.
That should not be a program.
Now, I'm pretty sure the bots are like AI based on like
other players.
That's so messed up.
Like they learn from players.
They learn how to cheese from other players.
That's funny as far, actually.
That's really good AI learning.
So that's why they can see the world.
They were learning from me.
Guys, I think they're pushing again.
I think they're pushing.
how the fuck did we keep getting behind i don't know how do
they do this how do these i'm gonna put turds on the i'm
gonna put turds on the guy i'm dead the ai just like uh no
clipped in there they just teleport into the car i mean not
yeah what the fuck yeah that guy is definitely ai there's no
way there's no way he's real
Oh my god, there's no way that guy was real.
He wants to- he wants to flank again!
Oh!
That was scary.
Whoa!
Goodbye.
Nice.
Yeah, I'm killing boss.
Yeah!
Oh my god!
Our peers has damage now!
I have 200 pick now.
Oh my god!
Wait, you're right.
This is actually a better server for you.
Told you.
I'm getting grieved.
They're grieving me on purpose.
Just request the server.
It's only one server.
San Francisco.
Wait, is it actually only one server?
Yeah, it is.
Wait, that's okay.
That's pretty funny.
I don't know how that's funny.
They're in the tunnel.
They should give us...
They should give us the Asia servers.
Japan?
Yeah.
That's way better for me.
350?
Yeah.
I mean, it would equalize everybody else.
Yeah, I would be using it.
Guys, C9, C9, guys, C9.
I got him, I got him, I got him, I'm doing it.
Because we were getting C9 again, guys.
Yay!
Easy win.
Holy shit.
Seven more minutes than we get to play.
Seven more.
Okay.
I mean, we won't too fast.
Like, we're just too good.
Okay, good IPNs.
11 feet, bro.
I healed more than you, though.
I healed the most.
How did I heal?
Apparently, they just started the game.
What?
No way, right?
Someone said they're just starting out.
Someone opened the stream right now and check.
Someone opened the stream right now and check for us.
I opened my own stream, my butt.
It's 2-7.
Yeah, it's 2-7.
whoever said that in your chat they're lying i got one guide
i got yeah but it made you open the stream you open the
stream though liar yeah my chat was lying my one guy fucking
lie wait are we playing the guy the team that's winning or
the team that's losing
knowing us we're gonna play against the winners how's the
turning going we're steamrolling yeah in like certain modes
yeah against bots like this we literally cannot lose our
round technically we broke our last streak yeah we went 9-0
last game no no we won last game remember we won we went 9-0
alright guys we're just waiting we're waiting at 7 more
minutes to until our next game will we hopefully don't get
9-0 it's 2-8 it's 2-8 oh it's almost time they shouldn't
have a break one more they should go straight into play
against us I put the Among Us lobby code in lobby thanks do
you want to play against our viewers too yeah hey viewers if
you want to join sure 4 it's Among Us Lobby It was green,
green!
Green!
Green DC alone ramp!
You wanna...
If you guys wanna join the Sherpa Sherpa will have people to
play with Yeah, yeah, he needs people to play with guys
Someone, please!
Green!
He's not even streaming He's literally doing this because
he's He likes them among us He's not even streaming guys Do
you actually like Amogus?
No.
Well, you don't, but you said you used to play Among Us a
lot.
No, I stopped playing because everyone would always first
time kill me because I'm too strong and powerful at Among
Us.
Yeah, that's why.
Yeah, I remember that, too.
I was also one of the Harbingers.
Guys, so don't kill him first.
That was one of the four horsemen of the apocalypse.
He was one of the first people that started the Among Us
bad.
yeah he was there look what you did look what you did you
fucking asshole among us ruin gaming everything it ruined
people and trust in and trusting to people you can't trust
nobody no more among us among us invented the term
gaslighting no it invented the term sus
out to play now i am getting your lobby codes yeah we are we
are on schedule we're actually early now we are early wow
don't worry i'm gonna post your among us code in your chat
as well sure for us so they know oh we're playing against
skibity rislers okay we can't playing the skibity admin are
they just are they good that has happened the score was nine
to two but who which team were they fighting against our
first team fighting against your first oh okay so we're two
points better than them yeah yeah yeah we got we oh my god
we got this we got this yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah we got this
guys we're two points better than them bring them to queen's
row and we'll show them
for the sake of this this is not on me this was pinged to me
by some of your community members out of the blue tell doki
to throw the game you have a debut to prepare for okay but
we can just win fast we can literally just win really fast
tell the enemy team to throw the game for me because today's
my celebration day i have to be happy here but look at the
levels levels five 13 9 9 11.
we are better on levels than them can you rename the bots in
this game just no just kick rpr put in a mess of the AI bot
rename it no that would be an improvement that would be such
an improvement dude you guys are laughing play on 300 ping
then play on 300 ping then play this is your choice right
now give her 300 this is literally your choice like you were
my life my rules i hate it here i hate this game i hate no i
love this game oh yeah oh dad remember this is all recorded
for the stranova dad nah nah but i corrected myself because
i actually do like this game but you guys make it terrible
for me Tails.
He says...
Well, you're gonna write it.
You don't even know what sadly was.
I've read heads.
RPR English or Spanish?
Eh?
Do you not know the meme?
Come on.
Oh, he doesn't know the meme!
I know it's English and Spanish and fucking dead, whatever,
who cares?
I don't play by your rules.
Just say English or Spanish!
I should have went Tails!
wait what do we get are you doing defense we lost we've lost
every coin they get the pick no we won the first no we won
first oh but we were always defencing because i chose
defense oh you don't even know which which side is defense
or attack side
ain't no way there ain't no weighing us oh my god we're
gonna lose again a defense side is b so are they in knowing
us what did we do among us I can't believe sure for didn't
actually start his among us lobby wait did you not no it was
bait we were gonna give you people to play with sure for
that's fucked um yeah wait can I oh my we can't trust you
can't trust the vtuber fans no cool they're during my
longest lobby and dox me
so see
oh what are we waiting for are they still deciding attack or
defense bro they just said ain't no way and then nothing
else yeah i thought that was one of the admins i guess we
swap oh they we yeah am i swapping i'll go here all right i
swap they want defense they made that grave mistake yeah i
thought but we always sucked at attack they made a grave
mistake we've done the worst jokes over your day welcome to
my world all right have we all figured out what we want to
if we're ready yeah they're calling you out man watch this
watch this is crazy yeah we're entering the game all right
which map is this shit wait that's a second silver say why
is this jack valorant man we are playing a wall hack bitch
what does silver say when they all i don't know Can I play
the healer now because we're attacking instead of the goo
lady?
I think so.
You can put whatever you want, man.
You know what you're doing.
I don't even.
Oh, I almost forgot.
Yeah, nades.
Almost.
I'm gonna run Flash.
I'm being slow.
Flash banged.
And win story.
Guys, do you think we can win, guys?
I actually do.
I do.
All right.
Don't die.
play like bitches okay shiver why don't you be idea why
don't you be idea i can't why can't shoot why can't because
if i age the demon comes out i know this map this is the
valoran map that's what i'm saying look they even have this
they have the flower pot in the admin instantly leaves as
soon as we start talking about valor Wait, which side are we
going?
I'm not the ideal, but I think B is nice.
I can easily push this with my wall hack.
Oh, okay, I'm with next then.
I'm with him.
Oh, my God, her boobs are in the 2D mode.
I'm good.
Oh, I'm next to you.
Oh, there's people here, yeah.
I got one on one on one hack.
Swing, swing, swing, swing, swing, swing.
Swing, swing, swing, swing, swing, swing, swing.
fucking win fucked me over here he's pushing up he's pushing
up oh sure for oh he's one though next next next be on you
be on it's one yeah oh my god i need there's two of them i
got one i got one i got one it's a 2v2 can i get sure for
how much time you got oh i don't know one more one more one
more up there rescuing rescuing oh that's the last oh he's
right here right here guys here revive me revive me throwing
bomb come to me come to me oh he's dead oh flashbang blind
i'm blind it's one guy it's literally one guy it's literally
one guy over there don't get one guide don't get one guide
please oh i see him i see him smoking i'm gonna play the
bomb i'm gonna put the bomb watch me
Are you still planning after that?
On the right side, on the right side.
I'm gonna slow him.
Oh!
That's a good shot!
That was a good shot.
Buy armor, buy armor, buy armor.
I'm gonna get heavy armor.
Oh my.
I'm not living long enough for regen, guys.
Number one, Vickro, lie.
Where are we?
Who are we pushing?
Now get down.
I just do the same thing.
I'll just follow next then yeah i'm gonna make sure guys
rule of thumb is do until it don't i'm gonna i'm gonna cue
this this door because that's how he got us last time yeah
yeah yeah someone hold that and then see me do until no more
work one to the right side i'm looking i'm looking for us i
built a wall i built a wall he painted it right now yeah
killed there they're gone go right or no i got i'm looking
at our flanks guys i want to wait until this i'm smoking
this that was bad that's my wall that's our wall i don't
yeah i'm gonna hold this i'm holding this yeah i'm gonna
plant yes you plant the bomba you plant the bomba i'm gonna
flash deep oh i've been spotted i've been spotted i'm
flashing i'm gonna throw a name i'm gonna throw a name here
I threw a grenade over there.
Got him, got him, I'm so good, I'm so good.
We got the bomb.
We planted.
Yeah, yeah, I'm covering for you next.
Yeah, they're not here, I think.
I got one.
Oh, nice.
There's one.
I'm going next.
I'm going to you just in case.
Close left.
Oh, they smell.
Two of them.
Okay, he's dead.
He's dead.
Nice.
On me and me.
Oh, shit.
I got another one.
guys we're actually playing villain
keep doing until no more no longer work we're looking at
corners and playing slow keep doing okay let's let's push a
let's push i what the fuck no let's push i push i push i
follow sure for because he's gonna push a i'm pushing i
we're gonna lose this right replace renova guys replace i'm
literally i'm just involved i'm gonna be insane i don't know
how they show up i've never played this map guys i'm making
wall i'm making a knife all right pushing pushing with the
wall i got two on scan oh that's teddy bear i smoke i smoke
i go in visibility mode i plant bomba no this map please
hold me it was bad it's okay the bear is coming over here
I'm playing invisible on site the bear I'm back Flank Toki
Oh my god Swing He's needed He's one Got his ass He made it
He made it Next next Next Oh Jet revive me I see bear coming
over here Three guys here Three Three dudes Oh my oh my Help
me Next behind you Behind you next Okay He's one He's
literally one No he's half I got flash I got flash I got
flash I'm not the best.
I got another.
Play bomba, play bomba, play bomba.
Okay, okay.
Just play bomba.
One HP on.
Yeah, we got bomb!
I think?
Yeah, we did.
Yeah!
We played bomb!
We played Trenova, guys!
We played...
We're doing it!
We're doing Trenova!
now we're running back b running back b running back b
running it back wait next yeah if you see someone you can
just literally double keem i'm gonna hold you okay like hard
w key what is your what does your thing you do yeah i give
you you become oh my god god your first call was right i am
always right i'm sure it's the right call Just tell me when
you give you pushing.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, I'm going, I'm going.
I messed up the...
I'm looking at the...
It didn't work.
Oh, he's dead.
Help me!
Help him!
There's more, there's more, help!
There's three of them!
Help me, help me now!
Man's bomb.
Oh my god, there's like ice bears and big bear!
Okay, I got one by the way.
Oh, I need to get bomb.
They're resin.
They got the res off.
No, he's coming over to finish the job.
No, shit down.
One more, one more.
Two more.
Okay, this is a 2V3.
Oh, that was a good name.
Fuck, he's long.
They're both here on me, on me, on my...
It's okay.
It's a 2V...
It's a 1V3.
okay anymore that's okay i'm clutch master you have five hp
we have a hundred and six the armor's fucking guns we're the
fuck killing me okay okay next next you become strong but
the fact that they shoot me from but not want me free strong
i was yeah i wasn't sure you know protestant was he standing
on that box what happened he said you're clutched back away
back away hey sometime sometime you winning sometime you're
winning sometime you're losing yeah yeah we go you only do
until it all work and then when no work we go on other stuff
but then last time always worked though but b didn't work
that game guys we got it guys we can't just suddenly stop
being teamwork okay guys guys teamwork all right oh one clip
one clip one clip all right that the wrong way what so for
no i i double push one shot sniper sniper sniper and a smoke
i'm why am i flying oh what the fuck okay did we have get
let's I've split the bomb, guys.
I'm protecting.
Who has the bomb?
Me, me.
But I can't.
They're everywhere.
I can bomb down.
Bomb down.
IPN.
Yeah, holding.
Okay, I got one.
Oh, there's another.
I got my one.
Bomb down, bomb down.
Nice bomb.
I'm here in the water.
Guys, RPI, I'm so safe.
I'm blind.
Get fucked.
RPI, I'm so safe.
RPI, I trust me.
Yeah, okay.
I'm going to die for you.
I...
Okay, didn't work.
Oh, no, it's a turret.
Oh, no, oh, no.
I got this, I got this, guys.
I got this.
Did you actually got this?
2v3.
2v3, sit your way, son.
I'll kill you.
Yes, good, good, good, good.
Got him.
Wait, RPO has 200 ping this time.
He actually has good ping.
Does anyone else wants to plant the bomb?
No.
We're going beast.
Give me some score, IPN.
Okay, you can go plant it.
You're the support!
Support always plant bombs!
Go B!
Suka, blet!
More B long!
Oh, we succeeded A!
What if we all stand like this and they push and we just
drop?
Not true.
I'm down.
Alright.
There's no way they'll see us, right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
There's no way.
We're just a bunch of enemy girls here now.
Hold on, oh, V9 is coming.
Okay, now they'll see us.
clear be long clear okay we're fucking around we're fucking
around right now even though i don't have a lot of time yeah
they're not really coming i'm pushing all the way below he's
on the side not coming they're not coming i feel like we
should help oh there they know they know they go a go a how
do we go away from here there's a bear there's a bear
there's a bear there's a bear there's a bear there's a bear
there i'm getting they know they know they know okay let's
flip around guys they're coming they're coming oh no i'll
kill you guys we're not pushing my dogs no no no no we're
pushing oh whoa you're dead guys why are we saying a middle
map no reason okay okay we go we go we go that was my need
that was my need sorry i didn't know we were gonna go there
i didn't know we were gonna go there they're watching middle
middle oh you're so good One more in the right corner.
Kill them.
Kill donkey.
Nice.
I was reloading.
I need reload two.
Two more top mid.
Wait, wait, wait.
I'm building a wall.
Just move.
Okay, I'm gonna go the other side.
Nice.
Get the bomba next.
Get the bomba.
Where's the bomba?
Did I?
I don't know.
Someone got the bomba, bro.
Kill them.
On site.
Careful on site.
The ice girl.
Where's the ice trout?
Oh my god, the reload.
No!
Why are you diggling?
Why are you digging?
That's how to reload my other gun!
But by the other pistol.
Okay, guys.
My, we're going to be side.
You guys know AFK in mid.
I wall.
Yeah, yeah.
We got to stop walking around, guys.
It's 4-2.
They can turn this around.
No, I won't.
You fucking around.
My wall is opaque.
i'm serious wait someone is a okay i was like who's that afk
okay i'm queuing this right side i take bomba i don't know
why i'm queuing right side maybe all right okay this is
clear oh shit oh i've been spotted i've been spotted by
fushia okay they know about our i'm going the right i'm
looking at right side wait i'm coming i can't i i cut off my
head I got rid of the bear got rid of the bear they're
trying to push.
That guy got smoked.
He got smoked.
I'm gonna oh, there's a there's a guy I'm looking I'm
looking I'm all the way every shop behind.
Oh, one one.
Where am I gonna shop from?
Black bomb Black bomb Wait, she's up.
She's up.
She's behind you man.
Oh shit.
Oh I was looking at the other guy.
Wait, it says self revive like yeah, it's there's who she
has a self revive.
You have to double tap her voice is like oh i got two guys
above me coming from behind one guy in front me coming from
the front it's not real or like oh wait i think it is a
passive i'm not sure two guys in front of me fuck i'm dead
sure for his time for the clutch the clash they're diffusing
oh did they oh they diffused guys we need to stop we need to
stop this is a defense map you know stop this three metal
bullshit Go 3b, 2b, Del.
I'm healthy.
4b long.
Be free.
I'm going to RPR.
One of our biggest problems as team is some of you just
jerks off off in midline for no reason.
Well, I'm covering.
Wait.
Midline bad.
Who are you covering?
Bomb site?
We on tech.
Do you just think you always deal in mid?
Just like bait them, you know?
Oh, okay.
I'll bait them.
Throw granata.
i can literally cut off the entire half of the b site yeah
we plan for free plan for free then we play time smart spot
it doesn't matter go up wait behind oh my god all three all
three are on mid all three mid all three mid i'm planting i
had to cover like two angles
no no i fucked up behind behind where we came from and
they're all they were all no shot i got one i'm kidding you
oh no no no how did you hit that you cheater
bruh i think we did a new strat i don't think we should go
be any all right i don't know so once we get the bomb though
we just have to play defensively once they're all around the
okay now i play this lady okay what if i i'm throwing i'm
throwing guys guys guys believe in the believe in the vision
guys right here oh she's playing oh wait sure for you can
rest people of your abilities yeah but i have sniper rifle
believe in the vision guys i'm playing a male character oh
no he has a dick oh i thought we're trying what happened
don't worry this guy's goaded i thought that's how we're
trying yeah we are trying this is i'm doing this for for us
chad which is better this one or this one i'm gonna be i
don't know i've never played this man so i don't know where
to put my turrets uh you we just attacked you know where we
come from or where they come from yeah but not really i
don't i don't remember i guess i could I'm trying to figure
out where they come from.
I got professionals in chat.
Healing, thrown, operational.
I am holding, I am holding Medell.
Someone needs to hold A.
Okay, I go.
Someone needs to hold A, yeah.
I'm trying to figure out where to put turrets.
I'm close quarter combat only.
I guess I could put a turret on the site.
Push me, push me hard.
I don't see A.
Push me to the zone.
I'm which I pin.
I'm going behind him.
Guys, I forgot to get the nays.
I was so confused.
I'm a YouTuber right now.
What behind?
I'm blind.
They smoked us.
I'm going to drop the ground.
I'm resting.
Reser.
They're top left mid.
Top left mid.
Okay.
On me.
147.
Can we heal myself?
I'm fucked.
They're so deep into A.
I'm heading over.
Planted the bomb.
I don't know where they are.
They're all like, can you use pink?
I am.
of you ducky okay i'm gonna come over i got my two i got my
two did you search like in our spawn i thirst to one yeah
they're both dead they're both dead oh no oh i i thirsted
one of your kills it's a 3v2 oh i got one as well oh my god
one v2 one v2 stitch away he's gonna rest over here yeah but
the bomb though yeah no he has this i don't know where they
are he's literally Goodbye.
I saw that.
I'm like, goodbye.
It's okay, guys.
We got this.
I need to know where to put my turrets.
Let's see.
You will not kill my allies.
Guys, I cannot play A or B.
I can only play mid because I'm shotgun.
Alright.
I'm putting turrets on the site.
And I'll put it over here.
Okay, I go B, I guess.
Oh, I'm B right now.
We can kind of play off the B side.
We don't have to be on the B side.
As long as we have mid, we can retake B at any given moment.
Trying to figure out how to defend.
Smoking me and Medell, and they're wall hacking me, and
they're cheating.
It's not long.
It's not B.
Yeah, it's A.
They're going to help cheer for you.
I'm doing.
I'm just going to make sure.
I'm going to head.
I'm rotating.
Oh, they're rotating back.
Returning back to B.
Yeah, mid, mid, mid.
They're coming mid.
Okay.
Come on, mid.
Next, we got a crossfire.
No, we don't.
I'm smoked.
I'm here.
Yeah, they rushed me too at the same time.
I'm looking from here.
There's two.
There's two over there.
Oh, they used an ability on the onload.
I might need help.
Who the fuck is your cops coming?
My bad.
Guys, they're calling an ambulance, but not for me.
I'm pushing up.
I can look from the flanker here.
Okay, one.
I got one, I got one!
Nice, nice, nice.
I'm flanking.
Climbing on you, climbing on you, doki, doki!
I got my guy, I got trade, I got trade, I got trade.
I got bomb, I got bomb.
Here, here, here, here.
That's the last guy.
I'm gonna try and get doki up.
Yeah, yeah, he's pushing me away.
Fucking stop!
Leave me alone!
Okay, that guy was pushing me up back.
He's killing me.
Yeah, yeah, it is.
I can't aim.
I got you this corner.
Look at it.
He's alone.
Just push him.
Just rush.
Okay.
It's only him.
Go.
He's in the corner.
I'm going.
Oh, no.
He's one.
He's literally one.
Come on.
I have a sniper rifle.
Wait, Shepha.
What made did you have?
I didn't have any nades.
Oh.
I.
use them okay guys this is way too close i don't know hey
start stealing okay listen to me actually just leave b side
don't even play up there okay play three in mid and then if
they take b we can retake it's so easy to retake this stupid
yeah i'm just putting i'm putting turrets up for us just in
case yeah and just play play mid towards a i feel like a is
way harder to i'm gonna I'm gonna put it on the side behind
here.
So if you run here next, I can like back you up here.
They're not coming here, yeah.
They're coming in the left mid.
Whatever the fuck that is.
I don't even know if like I'm in a good spot when it comes
to...
I'm blind!
They're not mid yet, I'm looking.
I'm looking too.
I have a wall hacking five.
Oh, hey, hey, there's one A site somehow.
Hanging over there.
I see two on A.
Okay, no one made, no one made it.
It's A, it's clear.
Okay.
I'm heading over here.
I need helping.
I'm here.
I got one.
That guy was funny.
Oh, there's a guy.
There's a guy to my left here.
Yeah, I can't push him.
I can't push him.
I'm a sniper rifle.
I know.
I'm trying to.
He's 97, 97.
I cracked him.
Playing his goal.
I tracked another guy.
There's one.
One dead.
I don't know where the others are.
Oh, no.
No, no, no, no.
He's down there in front of me.
I don't have a ping in the face.
Is he fusing?
He's right in front of me, he's right in front of me.
One HP right here.
Yeah, I did it.
He did it.
Got him.
Nice.
We did the turn.
it don't please every time we got overconfident and we out
just play like we did all right i'm heading over to that mop
turrets i'm just gonna put it here oh i have i have a i have
my alt for a retake if we need to use it we have four olds
yeah i have Heroes never die.
Heroes never die.
Wait, so you're on mercy.
Surefire's a mercy player.
Made, made, made, made.
No one's gonna be my kitten.
No, they're also, they're over here too.
Look at this next.
Wait, wait, behind behind.
They're here, they're right here, they're right here.
On your right, on your right, RPR.
Fuck!
Maybe I should have went forward instead of backwards.
They're all getting down!
It's B guys!
B!
Me then B!
They all took B!
I'm putting my turret down, but I don't know if it's
working.
I really can't see.
Next is crazy.
They all took the other side.
They all took my side.
Oh, I got him!
Yes, Doki!
No!
They see!
One more on Doki's body.
On Doki!
his body they're raising they're raising they might raise i
got one above you guys i swear above you guys on the left
inside always he's on side he's low he's low he's one more
there's more there's more there's a lot top mid yeah one b2
one b2 he's inside he's inside low no no no no no here nice
diffuse diffuse bomba we're time oh yeah i picked me up
I need helping!
Help me!
Imagine if you push into him and he can't!
You watched him die!
Okay, I got Phoenix ult.
I got Phoenix ult.
Okay, I...
I think what I do is I Phoenix ult right here, next, and I
run it down mid like a fucking idiot.
Okay, I will install like Volhek and tell you where they
are.
Okay, perfect.
I want to suck your blood.
Where did that come from?
He's gonna like count Dracula for a second.
Yeah, there's only one to the left.
They're pushing like, oh, there's another one.
Yeah, there's two, there's two.
There's four of them, there's four of them.
Next, you should not be sacrificing your life.
You do not have Phoenix salt.
I Phoenix I noticed Wait there's someone on me There's
someone on my They pushed the far side That is true He's not
lying Their body shot They're one I'm gonna stay here I'm
gonna anchor I'm anchoring B I'm anchoring B just in case We
left mid So she's dead on B in three seconds No I'm not I'm
still alive I can heal you next Oh Where are you There's
nobody in B There's nobody in B yet
Leave it Leave it if you have to I got the opportune spot
There's a sniper There's a sniper on Let them go Let them
come in They're all coming to me They're all coming to me
Okay pull back Pull back Play defense They're coming up
They're coming up Two guys top right Two guys top right Fuck
is this guy shooting at Huh?
Wall hacker Are they Rotating Are they seeing it?
Yeah, yes My turret Yeah, yeah, they're here.
They're breaking turrets right now.
Yeah, they are.
They are wall hacking me.
Oh, they flash this.
I'm on slow,
I'm slowed.
They're pushing us here.
They went high ground.
One stop on me.
If you peek me, I can heal you.
What?
To my right, guys?
No one's holding right, son.
I couldn't.
I had to back up.
I got one.
But I'm knocked.
I got knocked too.
There might rest.
One point, one point, one point.
Yeah, I think you can...
Fuck, he's low.
It's fine.
I advise myself.
I killed him.
Play time.
Okay.
Dude, he's so fucking...
I'm playing bomb.
I'm just...
Yeah, don't peek me, bitch!
Yes!
No peeking!
No peeking me!
All right.
This team is...
There's issues in the brain.
It's in the brain.
Yeah.
Why do we play better when you speak Russian English?
What talking?
What's talking about?
No picking me!
You die!
Hey, joke's over.
You guys want to pick me and I can flash this, but on this
one.
No one made.
I have a feeling they're rushing me, eh?
Yeah, no one made.
No one at all.
Yeah, the wall they walled.
I'm going behind.
He said the visibility wall.
Hanging over Floating thing.
Oh, yeah, they are there across across they got me walking
looking they smoking He here he cheating wal-hawk on my body
on my body.
He's one.
He's one IP and I body shot him Wait, no Wait.
I don't see anybody.
I don't see anybody Got one got one We're not right now on
our right.
Yeah Oh, they smoked me.
They smoked me.
He's pushing.
He's pushing on you guys.
On you guys No, the two of them I don't know if I can help.
I knew they would push me like that Oh, I traded.
I traded.
I don't know if it was not worth it, though.
One V4, one V4.
One V4.
This is clutch.
Oh, not clutch.
That was close.
Guys, lock in.
Lock in.
We're trying.
We're trying our best.
They might push A now that they know that.
They're not going to do that again.
How do you ping in this game?
Z, Z.
I mean, you can rewind it.
They fucking, they take this fucking lift for free every
time.
So I might just play right here.
but someone has to watch like mid okay if i'm watching i'm
watching here so if they are pushing i'm gonna look down
like but i have a shotgun so i can't do much but uh just if
they're pushing a just like play that that corner you might
push a again because they realized it wasn't an easy take um
i don't see anyone mid oh yeah they're going yeah there is
one mid one mid i've been fucking hell she's one i think
she's did i kill her gotta get her but she's gonna rest
there's two there's two more there's two more i can't get
the revive no no no you're way too far you're way too far uh
he pushed out and ate me i'm looking for you one right here
i see him i see him they're rotating yeah yeah i see the
rotate they're going back i'm going back too my turret is
still there so
yeah they're they're going hard yeah careful careful next
i'm running him up for my life i think they're gonna be long
all of them yeah the snipers one mid one mid one mid one mid
no two three mid three mid i'm splashing them careful next
yeah i'm coming back oh they smoked me they they smoked me
so i can't see anymore backing out They're gonna go for a
normal bomb plant, I think.
He might go through the...
Ceraflank!
He's dead.
They're going there!
They're planting!
Nice!
Bomb down!
There's a... Oh shit!
They're behind, behind!
I got him!
There's one up!
There's one over here!
She's low!
She's so low.
On point, on point, one.
On point as well.
That girl is low, but she has armor.
He's planting, he's planting.
He's bad.
He's bad at the video game
I didn't realize my ult.
I can just do it worldwide so I could arrest our fear that
whole time Nice, did you even use your res?
Guys, I think shotgun guys 4,000 damage
We push the key, guys.
I'm the only person in this team who has gotten an MVP.
What?
No, I got the...
Boo!
You got SVP.
Shotgun guy was mistake.
Shotgun guy was a mistake.
It's okay, we carried you.
That's okay.
Yeah, but I carried attack.
I carried attack.
We did it!
We won a game, guys!
We won a game.
Look at us!
Oh my god!
We're not...
that bad you guys have won congratulations yeah yeah i feel
like this was like i feel like this was like the battle of
the mids i wish we were in group b we should have been in
group b guys it was the middle of the year dude hey one w i
take it yay guys i'm proud of all of us we did not get
stomped except at one time but no we don't talk about that i
was mvp that game you want me mvp up the game when you got
stomped which means i am most performing all right that
makes sense now ggs guys i had a great time i have to go
prep for my minutes late i have to go prep for my debut
stuff i had a great time ggs i'll see you guys tomorrow when
we do this again we win ggs got okay we're not gonna win
against that we win the tournament the team with the night
oh we warmed up ggs guys ggs bye bye bye bye bye everyone
bye bye bye by adamin adamin bye by adamin all right
everybody okay i have like an hour and a half to fully prep
for the model day suit date oh my gosh strenova is fucking
me up skin suit debut my version because i'm gonna be a
model that's why i said model debut i'm gonna anyway anyway
guys i am going to go prep now we won our one game chat we
won one game out of three that's all that matters one out of
three hey guys i am going to head off now as always
everybody stay hydrated posture check get up and move around
to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me stay
below longer because I have the skin suit revealed in an
hour and a half.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.